and an update to a story we covered last
night Portland police released photos of
suspects in violent Antipa clashes that
injured conservative writers and others
and according to News Buster's CBS NBC
MSNBC and the New York Times all ignored
the ante for violence and beating of
Andy no joining us now is host of
reality check with David Webb on Fox
Nation and columnist at the hill David
Webb and author of an intro to the model
report Harvard Law School emeritus
professor Alan Dershowitz a David I'll
go to you first you know I I always say
the the irony of conservatism is
conservative governance and cities
benefits conservatives and liberals
right yet the opposite is true for
liberalism it burns liberals and
conservatives at the same time I mean
look at the Giuliani years compared to
what's happening in New York right now
with DeBlasio cities falling apart yeah
I mean the reality if you look at
Dinkins to Giuliani and what happened in
New York what happened was proper
policing in law enforcement that's not a
left or right issue and law enforcement
is frustrated I talked to officers in
Chicago not just about the Justi small
that case but about how they're policing
and and they feel that the mayoral
agency that runs the city doesn't have
their back it's not just the mayor but
it's the establishment and now you're
seeing the police in some form of a
revolt saying we just want to do our job
to protect citizens no matter what
that's common in law enforcement not the
outliers that you serve you occasionally
have and in the summer when it heats up
Dan you've seen this it's the hot days
of summer lead to a variety of things
that increase in shootings but robberies
are also up if you look at these comps
that report in these cities you're
starting to see it's a lagging indicator
but you're beginning to see robberies
you go to the precinct level the
complaints from the commander's the day
commander's this is a real problem not
only in Chicago but in many cities
around the country liberal run cities
now professor Dershowitz wherever you
see a liberal monopoly where they're in
charge in these big cities sadly many
times you see high crime you see
lawlessness you see some pockets of
poverty that seem unbreakable I mean
what's the common thread here obviously
it seems to be this liberal form of
governments at governance am i reading
this wrong I think you're reading it
wrong I think when Ed Koch was mayor of
New York
New York was a wonderful city I live in
New York part of the year now I think
it's a wonderful city I don't support de
Blasio for many of his economic reasons
but I think you weh-weh overstate the
problems in New York and attribute them
to one party rather than the other
Chicago is a different story Chicago
really has very very serious problems
some of the West Coast cities have
serious problems but I think they're
endemic often to urban centers where I
think we really do have a problem that
your initial of this point made was
about antiph I've been victims when I've
spoken at schools like Berkeley I've
been threatened by anti Phi and I really
do think the government has to do
something to stop extreme left wing
threats and violence to centers moderate
liberal speakers like me I'm not radical
enough for anti faso they try to prevent
me from speaking and that's been a real
problem on university campuses look we
live in a federal system and the federal
system gives authority to the cities to
make their own mistakes and their own
decisions the president really can't
intrude on that except in extreme cases
under the Supremacy Clause we have to
leave it to the cities and to the voters
to decide whether they like what they
get in the cities or not you know on the
legal analysis Dan I'll defer of course
Alan great to see you by the way looking
for the summer out there but you know
the Koch administration had done
something and I've had this discussion I
live in New York I love it like he does
that Koch had a relationship in an
understanding of proper police in a
neighborhood police and that's a key
difference unfortunately in these cities
that fractured relationship on the
antifa issue the FBI is waiting on them
their activities he's right about the
Supremacy Clause on a number of issues I
would never argue with his expertise
kind of ridiculous that anti-fur calls
himself anti-fascist as they go to the
streets and beat the crap out of people
kind of an interesting and a file if you
relegate your they've got to run